bonsoir journée de deuil national en ce
8 janvier au lendemain de l'attaque
terroriste contre la rédaction de
Charlie Hebdo l'heure est toujours au
recueillement et l'émotion après la mort
de ces journalistes de ces défenseurs de
la liberté d'expression et des policiers
également et en préfecture des ivelines
à Versailles à midi une minute de
silence a été observée dans la cour
d'honneur les personnels du Conseil
Général de la Préfecture des
représentants des forces de l'ordre des
pompiers se sont rassemblés en présence
du préfet rérard Corbin de manjou et du
président du conseil général Pierre
Bédier le préfet a notamment rappelé
l'importance de l'unité face à ces
crimes barbares le préfet qui a choisi
d'annuler sa cérémonie de vœux de
vendredi non loin de là au Conseil
Général des Yvelines des banderoles
également des banderoles je suis Charlie
je vous rappelle la réaction du
président du département il a évoqué dè
hier un acte abject dirigé contre des
journalistes et la liberté d'expression
il se dit horrifié par cette barbarie
une minute de silence a aussi été
observé sur tous les campus de
l'université de Versailles SaintQuentin
en Yveline environ une centaine de
personnes regroupées au bâtiment ferma à
Versailles pour rendre hommage aux
victimes de l'attentat et défendre les
valeurs républicaine écoutez quelques
étudiants c'est très important pour
l'université puisque c'est une défense
de la libre expression hein euh
l'université est basée sur cette
expression libre et c'est quelque chose
qui est très très important pour nous à
l'université évidemment je suis vraiment
choquée de ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est c'est un acte
vraiment vraiment inhumain et
euh sûrement ces gens-là ils ont pas ils
ont pas
de le sens d'humanité ils ont pas
de sont pas des gens quoi c'est
important de se de se retrouver c'est
important après ou avant le silence d'en
parler et d'échanger autour c'est c'est
important de de s'expliquer la façon de
penser de de chacun et d'adopter enfin
une attitude commune raisonnable et de
pas se laisser entraîner dans des dans
des attitudes extrêmes pour reprendre un
esprit à ch à charlibdo c'était fuck
laine Mor auon et vive la liberté
d'expression et et d'information euh
on notera aussi que l'association
étudiante ICAR et des groupes étudiants
invite journalistes et citoyens à
prendre la parole à l'université de
versaill saintquenttin en Yveline
vendredi à 18h30 au bâtiment vauan sur
Guy en cour ils l'ont annoncé dès hier
soir lors du rassemblement spontané qui
s'est tenu au pied des locaux de TVfil
78 on vient rendre hommage à toutes les
personnes
assassinées
aujourd'hui pour avoir utilisé la
liberté d'expression
et plus largement à toutes les à toutes
tous les journalistes et toutes les
personnes qui sont mortes pour pour cet
exprimer rendez-vous à 18h30 à la
mzanine vauan ce vendredi pour des
prises de parole citoyenne et on espère
que la presse locale sera là aussi pour
témoignner de leur métier et de ce que
c'est que le journalisme dans la qu
totalité des communes de France la
minute de silence a été respecté devant
les hôtels de ville c'est le cas
notamment au île Saint-Denis ou encore à
manilé àot les drapeaux étaient en berne
le maire a déclaré que la liberté était
un combat permanent et un rassemblement
républicain aura lieu samedi 10 janvier
au Parc Nelson Mandela à manie lesamo
donc des communes vont aussi dès ce soir
proposer des rassemblement à Bois d'Arcy
à 19h à la ferme de la Tremblet la
population est attendue avec fleurs et
bougies ou encore à plaisir un
rendez-vous sur le parvie du château en
présence des responsables des
communautés religieuses catholiques
musulmanes et protestantes une dernière
réaction celle de la communauté
musulmane des ivlines représentée par la
grande mosquée de mantelajolie et la
mosquée de Versailles dans un courrier
commun elles disent refuser que de tels
actes atteintes attentes à la cohésion
nationale les deux mosquées demandent
aux musulmans de participer au
rassemblement qu'ils soient locaux
qu'ils soient nationaux des propos qui
rejoignent d'ailleurs ceux du maire de
trappe guimalandin il invite sa
population à éviter tout amalgame toutes
drivvees racistes ou antireligieus comme
celles qui ont endillé l'Europe au
siècle dernier aujourd'hui et pour
toujours nous sommes Charlie c'est en
gardant ceci à l'esprit que je vous
propose de découvrir les titres de
l'actualité locale à présent la verrière
doit quitter le dispositif d'éducation
prioritaire en raison des nouvelles
règles fixées par le départe par le
gouvernement la ville se mobilise les
enseignants du collège intercommunaleal
Philippe de Champaigne était en grève le
vote du budget de l'Université de
versailles- Saint-Quentin en Yveline
reporté en raison de la mobilisation des
étudiants en décembre dernier le conseil
d'administration va se prononcer le 13
janvier faudra-t-il toujours faire
autant d'efforts pour sortir de la crise
nous en parlerons avec notre invité le
président de l'université et puis 4e
volet de notre rétrospective de l'année
2014 l'essentiel à retenir des mois de
septembre à octobre les enseignants du
collège Philippe de CHAMPIGNE étaient
donc en grève aujourd'hui pour protester
contre la sortie de leur établissement
des réseaux d'éducation prioritaire les
REP ils se sont rassemblés aux alentours
de l'établissement pour informer les
habitants du Menil Saint-Denis Mélanie
poquet en
colre en
colre des pas les enseignants du collège
Philippe de CHAMPIGNE n'ont pas assuré
les cours aujourd'hui 3 semaines après
l'annonce de la ministre de l'Éducation
c'est l'incompréhension qui domine on la
comprend pas d'autant plus
que ce qui nous fait mal au cœur c'est
qu'elle est justifiée par le fait que
entre autres elle est entre autres
justifiée par le fait que nos résultats
s'améliorent et que notre collège
fonctionne la perte des moyens ça va
être des moyens d'horaire des moyens
humains aussi en terme d'encadrement
euh principalement c'est-à-dire que et
on la perte des moyens horaires peut
aussi impacter sur les effectifs de
classe l'établissement Philippe de
Champaigne c'estes 427 élèves répartis
dans 17 classes les collégiens viennent
principalement de la ville du Ménil et
de
l'avrière à l'hôpital privé de l'Ouest
parisien de trappe l'activité du bloc
opératoire a cessé depuis lundi les
praticiens étaient en grève à l'appel de
l'Union Syndicale le bloc pour s'opposer
au projet de loi santé du gouvernement
parmi les mesures qui fâchent la
généralisation du tier payant le retrait
des autorisations pour les hôpitaux
privés d'assurer des missions de
services publics comme les urgences une
minorité de patriciens prenait en charge
uniquement les urgences dit vital
résultat de patients opérés depuis 3
jours contre 90 en temps normal au sein
de l'établissement mais hier soir face
au drame qui touche l'ensemble du pays
la grève a été suspendue pour risque
sanitair les praticiens sont dans
l'inquiétude nous écoutons l'un d'entre
eux pevent se reproduire dans les jours
qui viennent et si les services publics
sont en difficulté même si nous on se
remet au travail de manière décalée il y
aura du temps pour
résorber l'affl de patient et dans dans
un contexte aussi
grave il nous a paru secondaire de
poursuivre notre mouvement il vaut mieux
être prêt et parer à toute éventualité
notre après motif de revendication même
si nous apparaît toujours aussi
important passe au second plan par
rapport à ce drame
national invité de ce 8 janvier Jean-Luc
vessère bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'université de versaill
Saint-Quentin en Yveline venu ce soir
pour évoquer la question du budget de
votre établissement auparavant tout de
même une réaction par rapport à
l'actualité à ces massacres cet attentat
hier contre la rédaction de Charlie
hebbdo vous avez tenu à associer
l'université c'est c'est bien naturel on
on l'a vu au début de cette édition à ce
moment de de deuil national il fallait
une communion et elle a eu lieu sur les
sites de l'université j'étais très
content de la laactivité des collèges
puisque j'ai envoyé un message à toute
la communauté hier soir vers 22h h et
bien finalement pour mobiliser sur les
différents campus à versaill à la
Faculté de droit sur vos bandes à
Lambert euh et ils étaient présents donc
moi j'étais sur le site de Versailles
pour dire quelques mot aux collègues et
puis bon pour c'était pas pour faire des
discours et pour faire une minute de
silence en mémoire donc des victimes et
pour témoigner de Ben comment dire de
notre émotion de notre colère une
émotion particulière vous l'avez
ressenti déjà moi moi-même j'étais quand
même relativementm les étudiants les
enseignants qui é prés et je pense tu
témoigné voilà donc aussi vis-à-vis des
familles des des victimes de cette
barbarie et puis pour témoigner de notre
attachement aux valeurs républicaines
dont la liberté de presse d'expression
qui est une valeur très importante pour
l'université pour les universités les
enseignants de pouvoir s'exprimer donc
il faudrait pas que cette barbarie cette
c'est vraiment une agression
caractérisée contre la liberté
d'expression de presse mais qui pourrait
s'étendre si on ne prenait pas garde
donc je crois c'est important que euh
les citoyens la France les Français se
mobilisent et je pense que nous
l'université l'univers on devit être
présent on en vient dans un tout autre
sujet qui sera forcément regarde
l'actualité un peu plus terisoire mais
il est au combien important c'est le
budget de l'Université de Versailles 5
ans en Yveline il a été présenté en
conseil d'administration mi-décembre il
n'a pas été voté puisquil y a une
intervention d'une vingtaine d'élèves
qui s'opposaient aux économie en gros
qui était proposé il disait vouloir
discuter mais qu'ils n'ont pas été
entendus est-ce que vous les avez écouté
ces étudiants depuis alors donc pour
rectifier préciser donc ce sont des
étudiants pas des élèves et ensuite le
budget n'a pas été présenté puisque j'ai
interrompu le conseil administration
immédiatement quand j'ai vu ce voilà ce
ce cette agitation dire qui puisque je
j'étais prêt à entendre les étudiants
condition qui sortte ensuite mais n avz
pas l'intention
de de quitter la salle donc moi je
trouvais c'est une atteinte si je puis
dire mais moindre celle que j'ai nous
avons début quelque part voilà tout
garder à la démocratie à la capacité aux
administrateurs de de se positionner sur
un un sujet important le budget d'autant
qu'il y avait des des personnalités
extérieures des représentants du Conseil
Général de la quéation de 50 ang donc
voilà donc je trouvais un petit peu
gênant on va dire ça comme ça pour
rester correct alors est-ce que depuis
vous avez échangé avec ces étudiants pas
franchement sur le fond du budget sur
les inquiétudes qu'ils peuvent avoir sur
les économies qui vont être réalisées
eux ils disent c'est pas à nous de payer
les poassés il va y avoir des des coupes
budgétaires il va y avoir moins de place
pour certaines formations alors
simplement euh donc il y a le budget est
un petit peu contraint puisque justeque
on va dire jusqu'à la fin du mois de
mars on est en relation étroite on va
dire avec le ministère des Finances ou
appeler ber donc il y a une certaine
contrainte qui qui s'applique regarde
des financements que l'État peut ou veut
nous donner donc peut nous donner je je
pense que ça échappe à personne que la
situation des finances publques voir
même des finances privées est un petit
peu compliqué en France donc moi je
considère que le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur l'éducation
nationale ou notre ministre madame
fiorazo fait ce qu'un peu pour soutenir
notamment les universités donc au regard
du contexte compliqué alors le le nôtre
est encore un peu plus compliqué
simplement je veux noter que 2015 sera
bien ça sera bien meilleur que 2014 vous
allez me dire c'est facile parce que
2014 était quand même assez compliqué
euh donc puisque sur le projet de budget
qu'on nappelle initial au début de
l'année donc ce sera le 13 janvier euh
donc est un budget qui est construit à
l'équilibre sans aide exceptionnelle de
l'État alors que je vous rappelle que
2014 on avait eu
26 à
l'université voilà et là bon on est on
est quasiment dans le vert cela étant
bien sû sû on a fait des réductions de
dépenses quelques gains aussi de
recettes et et donc on présente un un
budget 2015 donc qui est à l'équip et
qui puisé avec quelques quelques oxygène
si on peut enexpression au niveau des
différentes composants de formation de
recherche en terme de fonctionnement si
on rentre dans dans le détail vous avez
évoqué un petit appel d'air avec des
ressources qui sont un petit peu des
recettes qui sont un petit peu en hausse
surtout des réductions de dépenses mais
parce qu'on fait des économies sur des
marchés de de l'énergie par exemple ou
sur les PPP mais également on a un
public privé voilà exactement
excusez-moi partenarat public privé
également effectivement faut pas se
cacher qu'on a fait quelques réduction
de masse salariale aussi he donc on a
fait des efforts d'optimisation on va
dire de l' formation l'activité d'autres
activités également de et ça a une
incidence sur les conditions de travail
des étudiants c'est qu'il disent voilà
ils sont dans le rôle moi vous êtes là
aussi pour les rassurer dans mon rôle
aussi je suis pas là pour les inquiéter
je su pour dire voilà on est on
s'inscrit dans une dynamique positive
donc je vous dis pas que 2015 sera le
paradis pour autant que exist à
l'université de manière générale mais on
est on s'inscrit dans une voilà une
sortie de crise sortie de crise donc où
on va pour simplifier doubler les
crédits de fonctionnement donc pour
faire fonctionner pour faire acheter du
papier photocopieuse ce qui sort
classiquement sur le campus de de
gancour Saint-Quentin et sur versaill
les sciences on va PIR acheter des
produits chimiques des produits
biologiques pour faire des travaux
pratiqu par exemple voà les choix qui
ont été fait c'était les meilleurs choix
il y a pas d'autres alternatif j'imagine
que le budget que vous allez présenter
le 13 janvier donc au conseil
d'administration sera le même qui aurait
dû être voté au mois d'avant donc il y a
pas eu d'avancé depuis depuis un mois
juste une peti une petite avancée si on
peut dire parce que non seulement je je
vous j'essaie de de dire que le budget
2015 sera quand même plus favorable
notamment aux étudiants en en terme de
de notre métier de former les étudiants
que 2014 mais également en 2014 nous
avions geler les emplois enfin aucune
pour faire Simp aucune publication de
d'emplois et là nous avons ce qu'on
appelle des recrutements enfin une
campagne d'emploi sur 2015 qui est prévu
et donc par rapport à au mois de
décembre euh dans ce que je présenté euh
mardi prochain euh donc il y aura une
augmentation du nombre d'emplois qui
sont ouverts à la création le budget est
à l'équilibre pour 2015 dans le projet
que vous allez présenter au vote euh il
faudra aussi qu'il soit à l'équilibre
les prochaines années ça veut dire qu'il
y aura encore d'autres réductions pour
les prochaines années non non ça ce que
ce que je dis toujours c'est on a mis en
place un plan de retour à l'équilibre
donc contient parce que on on est à
l'équilibre en 2015 alors qu'on avait
prévu 2016 donc et je tiens à remercier
la communauté qui s'est mobilisée qui a
été solidaire euh sur sur cette action
et après le plan de retour à l'équilibre
effectivement comme vous dites justement
il y a un plan de maintien l'équilibre
c'estàdire que en 2016 c'est pas on va
pas tout ouvrir les portes
faire la fête ou je ne sais quoi enfin
ou acheter plein de choses ou de
nouveaux bâtiments non non non il faut
être faut être vigilant mais là en
sortant à l'équilibre en 2015 c'est
comment on peut progresser après en 2016
donc normalement on est sorti de la
crise donc c'est après comment on
améliore on a fait des économies mais
aussi maintenant ce que je dis toujours
au collègues c'est il faut augmenter les
recettes faut trouver des financements
ce sera ce sera tout l'enjeu juste une
dernière question ça veut dire que
l'université n'a plus de grands projets
aujourd'hui vous disiez pas de nouveau
bâtiment des choses comme ça pour alors
ce que je dis aussi aujourd'hui c'est
pas l'heure du développement quantitatif
c'est l'heure du développement
qualitatif donc des GR projets on en a
ça a pas de projet donc vous avez
sûrement entendu parler je crois que
vous avez intervieé il y a pas très
longtemps le président de l'université
Paris SAÉ donc on a un grand projet
quand même qualitatif qui peut qui qui
se traduit aussi par des éléments
financiers he donc il faut quand même
pas oublier je j'espère avoir l'occasion
prochainement de d'expliciter cela que
le fait que nous soyons dans le projet
Sacé enfin le projet qui est concret
puisque le 31 décembre 2014 cette
université Paris sa dont l'université
detina parti voilà don dont l'université
fait partie ça apporte des financement
pour la formation pour la recherche pour
la création d'entreprise donc c'est très
important pour ça donc là c'est un grand
projet pour l'université c'est c'est un
défi quelque part et ensuite on a des
projets plein de projets de recherche
scientifique on a on est partenaire
également sur l'ieep science pot à
Saint-Germain RL voilà donc on est
toujours on a ple succès et comme je
pourrais en témoigner jeudi 15 janvier à
l'occasion des vœux de l'université s'il
y a pas d'autres nouveaux problèmes je
je compte faire un panorama de tout ce
que les collègues la communauté a pu
réaliser en 2015 juste une toute
dernière question ce sera sur un chiffre
le montant du budget pour 2015 si est
voté donc le budget en recette c'est 147
millions en dépense c'est 149 millions
al je rentre pas détails tilité
amortissement et ce genre de chose voilà
mais malgré ces de s vous paraissent un
peu cont différence c'est il sera à
l'équilibre il sera à l'équilibre merci
Jean-Luc vessier président deuniversité
desaill 50 ans neline votre du budget
annoncé pour le 13 janvier 14h30 lors du
conseil d'administration qui sera
peut-être perturbé vous allez renforcer
la sécurité un petit peu Jere vigilant
vous serez vigilant merci Jean grisser
dans le reste de l'actualité locale et
pour la deuxè fois en 7 mois les Gard
d'in familiux de guillanc ont été
cambriolés au total près de 23000 € de
matériel volé par les malfras les
adhérents sont excédé comme a pu le
constater sur place Antony
r c'est par cet espace désormais
renforcé par du grillage et des barbelés
que les malfras sont entrés dans ce
havre de paix dans la nuit du 27 au 28
décembre les 60 cabanons des jardins
familiaux de guillencour ont été
cambriolé motoculteurs
desbroussailleuses ou encore coupe
bordure ont disparu au total près de 10
10000 € de matériel envolé c'est plus
qu'un rbol c'est un équirement quoi on
est vraiment un peu moi j'étais ça m'a
rendu malade même contrarié le le matin
donc ça m'a 2 TR jours j'étais contrarié
j'étais malade j'ai même pris froid
parce que j'ai pas j'avais pas arrêté de
faire des
allersretours avec bon il y avait la
police il y avait un peu tout le monde
recevoir les gens les jardiniers c'est
la deuxième fois depuis mai dernier que
les jardins familiaux sont visités pour
un préjudice total d'environ 23000 €
l'association a porté plainte et une
enquête de police est en cours mais les
locataires des parcelles ne peuvent
obtenir un remboursement de la part des
assurances il faut que ça soit
endure déjà et que ça soit des serrures
et non des canenas et étant donné qu'on
n'est pas c'est pas chez nous et ben il
y a les assurances ne fonctionnent pas
cette étendu d'un heectare 8 permett à
60 familles de cultiver leurs propres
fruits et légumes les représentants des
jardins familiaux souhaite
l'installation d'une surveillance vidéo
ils doivent rencontrer le maire de
guilloncour dans les prochains
jours du sport avec du tir à l'arc et le
concours annuel de la compagnie
desloncours qui vient de se refermer 350
personnes présentes PARM eux des
champions internationaux venus chercher
une place qualificative au championnat
d'Europe un arc des flèches et beaucoup
de concentration voilà les ingrédients
qui étaient nécessair ce weekend à
hlencour à l'occasion des qualifications
au championnat de France de à l'arc-enal
plus de 350 licenciers avaient fait le
déplacement aujourd'hui ça se déroule en
phase ce qu'on appelle ABCD c'est-à-dire
que vous avez deux vagues qui se
succèdent et il faut qu'il réalise avec
trois flèches le meilleur score qui est
peut atteindre de 30 points les
candidats devaient réaliser 20 séries de
tir pour se qualifier en atteignant au
minimum 570 points c'est de
l'autocontrôle si les arbitres ne sont
là que s'il y a un liti sur un sur un
cordon mais sinon c'est simplement de
l'autocontrôle chacun annonce ses points
il y a deux personnes qui qui prennent
les scores un qui contrôle le score donc
mais sinon chacun fait son son décompte
luimême c'est vraiment le respect et le
respect de
l'arbitre cette valeur de respect propre
tir à l'arc Sandrine vandionant la
connaît depuis longtemps médaillée de
bronze au championnat du monde de Tir en
Campagne l'année dernière elle compte
étau faer son palmarès en se qualifiant
c'est un weekend un petit peu
particulier parce que ce weekend compte
pour les sélections pour le Championnat
d'Europe donc de tir en salle donc en
fait on vient chercher nos
qualifications pour la sélection finale
quelle qualité faut être pour être un
bon tireur à l'arc je dirais avant tout
de la concentration une bonne
coordination et de la patience parce que
comme tout sport il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement et attendre attendre
attendre pour que les résultats viennent
au final Sandrine termine première exo
avec sopieem championne du monde en
titre de nombreux élan courtois quant à
eux étaient également au rendez-vous
Gérard boyadan lui exerce dans la
catégorie Super vétéran j'espère faire
quelque chose de bien quoi voilà c'est
on y va toujours pour faire quelque
chose de bien mais au-delà de ça c'est
vrai que la participation un championnat
de France c'est toujours agréable et
valorisant le club d'lancour est
récompensé par de nombreuses places au
podium occupé par ses adhérents Gérard
quant à lui termine second derrière un
autre élan courtois le prochain
rendez-vous vous toujours à hencour sera
le 14 février pour le championnat
régional
adulte retour à présent sur 2014 4e
avant-dernier volet de notre
rétrospective de l'année écoulée que
faut-il retenir de l'information locale
des mois de septembre à octobre réponse
Catherine
zulato une bonne nouvelle sportive pour
ce début de rentrée à partir du 18
février 2015 le vélodrome national de 50
ans Nivine va accueillir les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste un premier événement majeur pour
ce nouvel écrin du cyclisme tricolore
qui va permettre aux coureurs de
l'équipe de France de briller à domicile
septembre c'est également la mise en
place d'étape pour temps d'activités
périscola les animations proposé en
prolongement du temps de classe
certaines communes ont choisi de les
étaler sur la semaine après la classe
d'autres ont privilégié le décret àontt
qui permet de placer ces tape sur une
seule demi-journée par semaine enfin
d'aucunes ont opté pour un rallongement
de la pause du midi c'était notamment le
cas à
guilloncour le 8 septembre la directrice
de l'hôpital de bullon a été placée 20h
en garde à vue à la suite de cinq
plaintes déposées pour harcèlement moral
les syndicats évoquent des
dysfonctionnements depuis plusieurs mois
les élus voir rouge après la
présentation le 28 août par le préfet de
la région Île-de-France d'un projet de
schéma régional pour une grande
intercommunalité à 800000 habitants sur
notre secteur le projet engloberait 50
ans niveline Versailles Grand Parc MPa
plaisir et une partie de l'esson des
élus unis pour dire non au projet il
vient de livrer son dernier ronde
l'emblématique entraîneur de boxe
d'élancour Antoine farouia est décédé à
l'âge de 70 ans à la suite d'un cancer
si son dernier combat n'a pas été livré
sur le ring il aura marqué de son
empreinte le monde de la
boxe politique sans surprise Gérard
Larché sénateur UMP des ivlines a été
élu président du Sénat ce 2 octobre à
l'issue de deux tours de scrutin il
avait déjà été président entre 2008 et
2011 un retour au plateau pour l'ancien
maire de
Rambouillet les écoles et collèges
affichaient porte close ce mercredi 8
octobre une journée dédiée à la
réflexion dans les établissements
scolaires beaucoup de mairies ont
fortement critiquer cette décision à
Plaisir notamment aucune solution
d'accueil n'a pu être mise en place le
Conseil général a annoncé souhaiter
vendre le hara national des brevvières
dont il est le propriétaire une
véritable levée de bouclier de la part
des élus et des acteurs de la filière
équestre le département a annoncé qu'il
lançait finalement un appel à projet la
confusionit c'est le nom de la pièce de
théâtre mise en scène par Collette et
Valérie rummanov la mère et la sœur de
l'humoriste une comédie qui porte un
nouveau regard sur la maladie
d'Alzheimer et qui livre un véritable
message d'espoir une représentation a
été donnée à Versailles et toutes les
recettes ont été reversé un projet en
faveur des personnes âgées dépendantes
économie enfin Promopole pépinière
d'entre prise en cessation de paiement
c'est la nouvelle de cette fin du mois
d'octobre un administrateur a été nommé
une décision prise par la nouvelle
majorité de la communauté
d'agglomération de sa-quentin en Yveline
qui dénonce des résultats déficitaires
chroniques ainsi que des erreurs de
gestion et des fautes grave commise par
la majorité
sortante 2014 terminé qu'avez-vous prévu
de changer pour 2015 micro trottoir il
faudrait que je range mon garage et
toute ma maison mais ça c'est pas sûr
que j'y j'y parvienne on va essayer
d'abord de de faire que la santé soit
bonne et puis euh beaucoup de solidarité
avec tous ceux qui sont en souffrance on
va se marier d'être dans l'harmonie et
dans la dans la douceur le
sourir priorité absolue partout et dans
tous les
cas le journal va se refermer avec ses
images à Versailles en ce jour de
nationale à midi une minute de silence a
été observé dans la cour d'honneur de la
préfecture des ivelines en hommage aux
victimes de l'attentat donc perpétré à
Charlie hebbdo les personnel du Conseil
Général de la Préfecture des
représentants des forces de l'ordre des
pompiers rassemblés en présence du
Préfet et du président du conseil
général le préfet qui a rappelé
notamment l'importance de l'unité face à
ces crimes barbares demain le journal
vous sera présenté par Catherine zulato
tout de suite sur TV fil fileecco
présenté par Floran parfait et puis vous
rencontrerez sans doute quelques
difficultés à vous connecter à notre
site internet dont l'hébergeur a été
tout simplement piraté ce soir retour à
la normale le plus vite possible pour
pouvoir retrouver l'ensemble de nos
programmes bonne
soirée